hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the penultimate round
of the 2021 sinful cup it's maximus
allegra versus jeffrey xiong and just
when you think that everything that
could have happened already happened in
the berlin defense that does not seem to
be the case so let's check out this game
as it's quite a short one and quite an
enjoyable one so maxime with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 knight
to f3 knights to c6 and bishop to b5
going for the royal opus and knight to
f6
like we said that the uh berlin defense
is on the board we have castles by
maxime uh and knight captures on e4
accepting the rio gambit we have d4
knight to d6 and now bishop captures on
c6 so this has been played many many
times uh d captures and now d captures
on e5 going for that early queen trade
with knight to f5 and now the queens are
traded off the board captures captures
and now you have to decide how you want
to continue this
as a white popular moves are knight to
c3 rook to d1 h3 and so on uh maxime
chooses h3
and now we have bishop to d7 just
shifting the king over to e8 is uh
mostly played here but here xion goes
bishop to d7 first and now rook to d1
pinning that bishop uh we have bishop to
e7 and now knight to c3 and again this
position has been reached many times
even of course in top tier chess
the most notable game is the one from
the 2013 world chess championship match
between magnus cross and vishwanathan
anand that took place in chennai uh that
ended in a draw where king the c8 was
played and in every game that reached
this position king the c8 was played but
here we have king the e8 and it is now
as of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game so let's see uh what xiong had
in mind by uh well discovering this new
square for the king uh maxime attacks
for the knight first we have g4 knight
the h4 and now the knights get uh to get
traded off the board we have knight
captures bishop captures and now now
although f4 looks like a very nice idea
just you know creating that beautiful
pawn chain
uh giving black the h5 move so early uh
maybe
maybe not the way to go for and now you
could continue with g5 for example but
then you have a lot of light square
holes and if if you go for f5 then for
example captures captures and g6 now
black is just uh
doing outstanding here even if e6 and
something like captures captures there
is no way for this pawn to ever you know
become anything
so after this bishop to h4 we have
bishop to f for now
uh and rook to d8 uh we have king to g2
uh and the bishop back to e7 now and now
bishop back to e3 yeah putting pressure
on that a7 pawn so shiong moves it to
the a5 and now f4 but now it's a bit
different it's it's not that uh same
pawn chain that we've just seen yeah
even though black continues in the same
fashion we have h5 you could prepare it
by playing g6 first but there's uh no
real need to do that we have h5 f5 by
maxime and now h captures and g4h
captures and g6 so very uh similar to
the line that we've already shown but
it's also very different because now
rook d to h1 and now what do you do here
uh well you could try capturing here but
after captures captures the game is
simply lost for black there's no way to
handle all of the threats
to give you an example if you try and
grab a pawn here we're just going to
deliver this check rook to h8 to check
and now after bishop to f8 we can play
bishop to c5 and that's game over
there's no defending this
uh so
a thing you could do after this rook to
h1 is move the rook to g8 and this seems
to be the only way for black to continue
playing this however
in the game rook to f8 was played and
this rook on f8 is a big problem now so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for maxime while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the bishop really doesn't have all that
many squares and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course f6 uh we take away all the
squares from the from the black bishop
uh and after bishop to b4 we of course
do not allow bishop captures knight we
play knight to e4 and by doing this we
now again take away all of the squares
from from this bishop here because now
uh we are preparing c3 a3 can also be
played and even if black moves this
bishop and kind of gets control of the
d2 square with the rook we are covering
that with our bishop and our knight so
this bishop is trapped and with our next
move we're going to
uh we're just going to trap this bishop
uh and it's
a very difficult position for black well
it's a lost position of course it's
difficult but you can't really save it
if you play bishop to e6 for bishop to
e6 was played but if you try rook to g8
now trying to free up at least one
square for the bishop it's not a problem
for white a3 we can play bishop to f8
and now rook h7 and again there's
nothing for black to do here you you
could even grab a pawn here but still
just knight g5 go after the f7 pawn and
if bishop defends it it's not much
better uh matter of fact it's even worse
captures captures f7 check now wins the
game
so instead of trying to save the bishop
uh
uh shien tries to bishop to e6 so uh the
next move is pretty obvious we have c3
attacking the bishop here now bishop to
d
d5 pinning this knight here so king to
f3 only move for white
and now this should be back to d6 here
uh he's saying that okay maybe at least
i can mess up a white spawn structure uh
and maybe fix my own pawn structure so
maybe i will have something to fight
with but maxime says uh even though
capturing on d6 is fine i don't even
have to play that i'm going to play c4
and this is enough to win the game uh
and by doing this by playing c4 maxime
uh even
releases this bishop from its tomb but
it doesn't matter uh bishop captures an
e4 with czech king captures bishop to b
for now we have a3 and bishop to d2 now
the rook is covering the d2 square ones
so it's not a problem but now you lose
control of this diagonal so bishop to c5
by maxine now attacking the rook here
and well you have to move the rook rook
to g8 and now finally we get e6 and now
he was in this position on move 29 that
jeffrey xiong resigned to the game and
an amazing victory for maxine
vasherlagrov in the uh berlin defense of
the ruy lopez so uh we we often see yeah
you know not often but from time to time
crazy stuff uh happening in the berlin
more often than not with the black
pieces but here it just went wrong he
prepared that k8 move instead of king to
see it um but it just didn't go well for
him as i mean this this is a classical
game so uh
probably he had some some line played
that would offer him some some play but
the maxim uh
avoided it all and simply got a better
game and now you you don't really have a
move uh whatever you play let's say you
capture the pawn uh rook h7 and that's
it there's no defense against the f7
check if you try rook to d7 to guard the
f7 pawn we can simply capture it and
then play f7 we attack the rook uh and
of course we cover the queening square
with our bishop so whatever black plays
we're just gonna you know bring a queen
into the game and after rook captures
bishop captures we're gonna be up a
whole rook and other than that uh after
this uh e6 move you don't really have
anything better
uh
wha what could you play here uh you
could maybe play something like yeah
it's it's hard to even make a move here
you could attack the bishop here for
example but then bishop e7 attacks the
rook here and once the rook moves
somewhere there's really nowhere for the
rook to move you can just move it
anywhere and then we're going to play
rook 8 to d1 and then continue harassing
our good friend the dark square bishop
and well that's uh pretty much it bishop
to g5 now we bring the rook to h7 and
again nothing to be done here f captures
on e6 f7 check king captures we're gonna
capture here with uh a check bring your
queen into the game and that's it king
f6 and rook to f7 will be checkmate uh
one of the fun lines that would be
possible if the game continued in some
way uh but yeah after this e6 move uh
xiong resigned and what does this mean
for the standings we said that we were
going to cover three games before we
showed the standings so here are the
standings uh of the stingfield cup uh
there you have it maxine vashila grav in
first place with five and a half points
followed by
trio with five points fabiano corona
wesley saw in linear dominguez uh then
richard rapper with four points with
three and a half jeffrey schuen in
chakriar mahmoud yarov l and sam
shankland uh with three peter swiddler
and with two darius schwirtz uh so we'll
see what happens in in the final round
uh in the final round maksim faces
shakir mamadarov so uh should be uh a
fine clash for uh for deciding whether
maxim will win the sinful cup or not uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh thank you for uh you know always
suggesting great games for me to cover
uh i would like to thank david kimura
chair langdon consulting joseph kopresh
margin von vauden uh and audi kachoku
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the sim field
cup uh until it ends
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day